hello
so in the last video we looked at ranges
of forces
so we already saw one aspect in order to
learn about
what kind of interaction happens when
you when you study
um specific force you learn about the
force carrier from
noting the range in which forces
interact
in this class we talk about decays but
in more general terms when we
want to measure properties of forces we
have basically three concepts at hand
which can be experimentally determined
the first one is masses of bound stakes
so you might remember from atomic
physics that you learn a lot about the
electromagnetic interaction by studying
for example the hydrogen atom where you
have an electron
circling around the proton and you can
study in detail
in an aspect of the electromagnetic
interaction
um the second aspect is decay rates of
unstable particles or the width of an
unstable particle
so in quantum mechanics the lifetime of
the particle is related to the width
and so that's what we're going to
discuss in this video and then lastly we
can look at the
reaction rates expressed as cross
sections and that's topic of the next
video after this
so let's talk about decays um so we can
define
this new symbol the decay rate lambda
and s as a function of time the
probability that a particle will survive
at least until some time t um
we can now discuss this and say okay you
know the probability at some time
t relates to the probability at some
time t
plus delta t by the likelihood
one minus the decay rate times the time
interval
delta t and some from this we find
that the change of the probability for
the particle to survive
is proportional to that probability and
decay rate
so now if we integrate this we find that
the log
of this probability is equal to some
constant
times lambda decay rate times time
so now if you simply assume that the
particle existed
at the initial time t we said we said we
set
k equal to zero we find this very famous
exponential decay law e to the power of
minus
lambda t and this shown here in this
picture as you see this is exponential
so far so good um we can now
you know define and look at this
distribution a little bit more
um we can for example look at the
average time for particle
that a particle lifts um for this
average time tau
is simply given by the integral from
zero to infinite
so you basically integrate over this
distribution to get the average time for
the particle
and that's equal to one over the decay
rate one over lambda
so you can do the algebra yourself and
try to follow this
um so if you now express
this probability for the particle to
survive until temp time t
uh through the lifetime we find this is
equal to e
to the to minus t over the the
the lifetime of the particle so you
might
not want to look at one particle by the
ensemble of particles sum of particles
and look at the time dependence of the
number of particles which survived
so this is equal to the
number of particles as a function of
times equal to the initial number of
particles times the probability that any
given particle survives
and that's again given by this
exponential
all right in nuclear physics
one often talks about the half line half
life time of the particle or
specifically nuclei
and that's given as you would assume by
the time it takes
four half of the particles to decay so n
of tau one half is equal to the number
of initial particles and not over two
and you find then that this half lines
with
half half life is related to the
lifetime of the particle
within factor of about two thirds
yes this is uh leads to some confusion
in numerical values sometimes when
when you ask for specific answers for
nuclear so
any experiments
all right so there's another aspect of
the case which arises
which comes from a fundamental property
of quantum mechanics
so if you have an unstable state or any
unstable state does not have exact
energy state and this follows
if you want from the uncertainty
principle
so the width of a particle
is quantized and it's quantized with
this thing with lambda here and as you
can see lambda relates again to the
decay rate
over the lifetime of of the particle
another complication can occur when
there's multiple ways for the particle
to decay
for example you know you have a higgs
boson as you will see on the next slide
which might decay into multiple
has a way to decay into multiple
particles
here we define a partial width where
the partial width is defined as the half
the width of the particle to decay into
specific mode
and then the total width of the particle
is given by the sum of the partial
widths of all
possible ways for the particle to decay
using this you can also decay
to calculate the likelihood of a
particle to decay in a specific way
that's called the branching fraction and
that's given by
the partial width divided by the total
width
or the partial decay rate divided by the
total liquid
again the total has to be one the
probability for the particle decay in
any mode is one
therefore the sum of the function ratios
is one as well
all right so looking at a specific
example
um the higgs boson is probably my famous
favorite
example in this entire class um you'll
find here
given branch infractions or ratios for
specific decay modes this is not all
ways in which the exposure and decay was
the most dominant one
the most prominent one is the one where
the higgs boson decays into a pair of
beak works
um you will later see maybe even as an
exercise
why the distribution of branching ratios
is the way it's being shown here
so the higgs boson has been measured
with a mass of 125 gb in a little bit
and you see at this mass here the
vomiting decay mod is into pv bar but
it's also possible for the higgs boson
to decay into pair of w bosons
uh we are an interesting loop diagram
into gluons even so gluons are massless
or taus
charm zebras and so on and we just
showed here showed you in a paper which
was submitted today
to the archive that exporter also can
decay
into a pair of neurons with a branching
ratio of 2 times 10 to the minus 4. so
it's rather rare but it's possible